J Mo
moin ich habe mal zwei Fragen und
zwarreis basiert das auf Geschichte od
ausgedacht und was h für privat de
eigen was ich mich mal interessieren und
schönen Gruß aus Brem auf jeden Fall ein
schönen Gruß auch an dich zurück hast
auf jeden Fall den richtigen Song im
Hintergrund Teufelskreis basiert auf ein
Geschichte wobei aber jetzt nicht mit
den Charakteren in Zusammenhang sondern
die wahre Geschichte ist es gibt eine
Jasmin es gibt ein Hakan es gibt einen
Tarik nicht die tragen nicht diese Namen
sondern das sind Leute aus meinem Umfeld
wo Mensch a kan tarak sein B Jasmin und
c h kan also es ist eine Geschichte die
in der Form schon 100 mal irgendwie
reell stattgefunden hat und privat höre
ich natürlich country wenn wir schon
beim Thema country sind da kommen wir
dann auch wieder zu meinem besten Freund
den sido der natürlich auch wirklich mit
seinem Bart und seiner Brille schon so
leichten country Sänger ähnelt
und ja ich bin auf jeden Fall ein großer
country Anhänger ansonsten wenn ich
country höre ich
zurzeit was höre ich zurzeit dr dre
featuring Snoop Dog und Aken K yeah